una vez un paraíso hoy un lugar
regularmente azotado por la violencia en
la noche del miércoles dos mujeres
turistas murieron en un tiroteo en un
restaurante de tulum en la costa caribe
de méxico otras tres personas resultaron
heridas al parecer fue un enfrentamiento
entre mafias que se dedican al tráfico
de drogas si son temas de hoy de la
delincuencia organizada que de alguna
manera están tratando de
disputarse alguna algún área y pues
lamentablemente pues en este caso hay
daños colaterales que son que son los
que afectan a otras personas que nada
tienen que ver durante la pandemia tulum
reforzó su posición de líder turístico
por la falta de restricciones sanitarias
con la afluencia de dinero llegó la
batalla por el control del territorio
este viernes aparecieron avisos en un
mercado de tulum reivindicando el
tiroteo por parte de una pandilla
llamada de los pelones que operando en
la versión a cancún y asociada con el
cártel de jalisco buscarían extender su
dominio hoy los turistas temen por su
seguridad
sabes he estado mucho aquí en el último
año en tulum y playa y no estamos
acostumbrados a ver algo así en la
sección turística así que es un poco
aterrador para todos me gusta lo que
solía ser mucha gente en todas partes
haciendo cosas y ahora ya no ves esas
del plenario de adversidad del show uno
pensaría que serían muy cuidadosos al
garantizar que los turistas se sientan
muy seguros al venir aquí así que creo
que definitivamente estamos sorprendidos
de que esto ocurra hay que ver cuánto
tiempo tulum podrá mantener su fama y si
podrá evitar convertirse en una nueva
acapulco hoy una de las ciudades más
afectadas por la violencia